and then i was competing so
i just wanted to get better and stronger
i didn't have any coach telling me how
to do it so i was like well i'll just
figure it out on my own and i also
worked at five crossfit gyms so what
happens when you work at crossfit gyms
is people ask you to work out afterwards
there's other coaches around and so
they're like hey do you want to go do a
workout now like yeah i do so sometimes
i i was doing four workouts a day and
then my rest days i felt very guilty
about resting and so i'd run five miles
i would do row sprints i would do uphill
sprints and so my rest days were active
rest days body weight workouts
and i was never resting i was just
completely beating my central nervous
system down never recovering
and
but i was getting results i was
continually lifting heavier and i hadn't
hit the wall yet and i competed in
regionals in 2011 and then did better in
2012 i put 30 pounds on in a year by
simply
working out all the time yeah and
then i got 11th in 2011 and then 8th in
2012 and so some improvement
and
then in 2000 right after that regionals
i injured my shoulder in a workout
and that was my first like big injury
where it was like okay something's weird
how did i do that what were you doing a
snatch it was a one-run max snatch in a
competition and so i injured my shoulder
and so that kind of pulled me back a
little bit
and then i would look in the mirror my
acne was out of control i mean it was so
bad cystic acne all around my face i was
30 pounds heavier i literally looked in
the mirror and i remember crying my face
off because i'm like i don't know who i
am i don't recognize myself who is this
person
and now i'm thinking
what i'm whatever i'm doing is not
working
so i need to do the opposite
but my identity is crossfit
i am crossfit i've created that i am
paleo and so
saying that i'm not that anymore when
you when you're younger you're so
attached to
um identities
and so to say that i'm not a crossfit
anymore was like no way could i do that
yeah so i was like okay i'm just going
to cut back and you loved it it wasn't
that you hated crossfit loved it right i
love it you know i coached full-time
and
i you know was known for that in
community and all my friends were
crossfitters i met my husband at
crossfit like my whole life was around
it
and so
to say that i'm not going to go to the
gym as often was really hard and it was
really it made you feel like you were
lazy
when i'm saying like okay i'm only going
to work out once a day
and like instead of four times a day i
get it
like
i like to think that i went from maybe
21 workouts a week to five workouts a
week like that's a huge difference yes
so i was like okay no you're gonna stick
with it you are going to lift lighter
because your body aches everywhere and
you have injuries and you are going to
do way less workouts and you're going to
stick with this and i i cried through
workouts because the coaches and my
friends there would be like why aren't
you doing 95 pounds
why are you using 365 yeah why are you
rxing it why aren't you why aren't you
rx plusing it yes
and they're like no put more weight on
the bar and i was like come on julie you
know you can do more yes and these were
people i looked up to and they were my
peers
and they're like julie come on don't
don't do that you're a coach you need to
do prescribed and i would cry through
workouts knowing that i could physically
do do something and i wasn't doing it so
and i but i told myself i'm gonna do
this and so i started trying other
workouts too i'm like okay maybe i need
to do more uh cardio based stuff and so
then i started doing orange theory
you know same hit style training
longer workouts yeah but very high
intensity um
did you notice a change when you started
sort of shifting the programming no okay
i didn't see a change i felt more so
like
it was leading to injuries because it
was like non-stop running sure going
through
tons of repetitions
so but i just was trying to find my new
thing my new identity i just needed to
find a new identity and so orange theory
didn't work i tried pilates i tried have
you ever tried a versaclimber class no
but i've tried a versaclimber for sure
yes i've definitely used the verse
clamor they're brutal they're brutal
brutal but you you're so addicted to
pain
and yep putting your body through pain
and you think that if you didn't work
that hard and you're not drenched in
sweat that you didn't really work out
yeah that you're not getting anything
and you're not going to see change
and so
it was step by step i started
decreasing my weights more and more in
crossfit and
it took me three years but i lost 30
pounds in three years that's amazing i
simply yeah cutting back which is like
normal weight loss for a human being
and
just by slowly cutting back in weights
and being more lenient with my diet
because i was like eating a ton of nut
butters because
you know that was kind of where paleo
was at sure
nut butter doesn't work well for me and
my skin issues so why am i doing this
i'm gonna have some more potatoes
instead of having a higher fat so you
think there was a big calorie shift or
do you think it was just
some sort of energetic freedom food
freedom i think both you know because
like it's one thing to change the food
and be like not mentioned that you're
eating drastically less calories or or
less calories
but sometimes i think there's some
energy behind it too of just not getting
attached too much not thinking so much
about the weight more about the
um
enjoyment more about the freedom less
punishment more flow well and it's less
cortisol then because you're not
stressing yeah so that's what i think
was one of the main things i definitely
obviously calories
are a huge part of
uh weight loss
but i think that shift in
uh stress hormone that happened in my
body by working out less and by
stressing less about food yeah because i
just i stopped thinking about it all the
time it didn't consume my entire day
and
so i slowly started losing weight
feeling so much better i would wake up
without aches and pains
and then
the less i did crossfit the better i
felt and the more i wanted to try
different types of workouts so i wanted
to try more strength based workouts so i
started doing more bodybuilder style
workouts where you're doing a 3x10 or a
3x6 or a 2x12
very simple things where i'm not
increasing my heart rate
that much you know you get a little
spike and then it comes back down but
it's not crossfit where you're tasting
blood in your lungs
where you have to lie on the floor
afterwards you're more so like oh oh my
butt's cramping a little bit
your legs are feeling tired right but
you're never laying on the floor
acting like a dead fish you know like
wailing in pain
and
i started doing that and i continually
felt better i didn't have pain in my
traps anymore which i had had for
seven years i didn't have any head traps
too yeah because when you clean the bar
and you pull it up
constant cleaning constantly actually
since i've done less crossfit too
because i really haven't been to a
crossfit class and
it doesn't mean i haven't done crossfit
moves i mean i still clean the bar i
still i mean you still do some of that
stuff too um but i don't do crossfit
exact like only and it's probably been
what was that it's probably been since
the beginning of 20 so it's probably
been a year and a half and
one of the things i noticed is that when
i put my um
purse on my shoulder with the strap
it doesn't just fall right off because
when your traps are so big things just
slide right off yes
yes i was thinking about that the other
day that's like so funny
my strap stays on my shoulder now yeah
yeah like you're
you get huge traps of crossfit because
there's so much pulling motions like you
just do so much pulling and i
noticed as i started getting into these
different style workouts so much what
was lacking in crossfit like a lot of
unilateral movements a lot of lateral
movements yeah i
had really not much strength in my inner
thighs and outer leg like i just was
missing a lot of strength in my glutes
and i started doing a lot more glute
work because i just wanted to build a
bigger butt but it really improved my
squat i didn't have hip pain anymore
that i had had during crossfit so i was
seeing these really great improvements
from doing less crossfit and then i
would go to a class and just drop into a
class
and i have
a competitive nature just comes back and
i don't i don't want to lessen my weight
i don't want to reduce my weight
and i don't want to be last and so i
push it really hard yeah and we talked
about this so it's so hard you go in
there and you're like you know it's like
an addict and you're like
oh i can totally do bar muscle ups i
haven't done them in a year and a half
but why not yeah let's do it like the
open came about this year and it was
like the open had a had a um a clean and
jerk and then bar muscles up in the same
workout it was like something with bar
muscle ups and then afterwards you had
to find your one rep max for a clean and
jerk and i was doing bar muscle ups and
i mean i can do them but i hadn't done
them in at that point like i don't know
a year and um or nine months at least or
something like that maybe over a year
because i had done a lot less hanging on
the bar even when i was there at the end
because i felt like my upper body was
just so built yeah and uh
but i was like screw it it's the open
and i was by myself so imagine what
happens when i go to an actual actual
gym and i get like you know
prodded into or like my own guilt really
it's not anybody else always and i did
them and i i did the clean and jerk too
and i was surprised that i did i think i
got like 135 for the 130 for the clean
and jerk and i was surprised